So, we're talking about $1.9 billion in
state disaster funds um that could
potentially be denied if you are a US
state or a city that is boycotting
Israeli company companies. You're just
going to be denied federal aid for a
natural disaster. Say you get hit by a
hurricane money that is for the backup
power systems among other expenses.
And Trump is saying, "Yeah, no, I hear
you. I hear you screaming. I hear that
that's a hurricane." And you know, maybe
it's wiped away your entire family, your
entire house, but do you support Israel?
>> I'm telling you, they're going to kill
this woman.
>> Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Asalama
to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys inshallah. Do not
forget to download the Salah Pro app
inshallah. Absolutely free, ads free and
it is at your service inshallah to it's
the first app that encourages you to
pray salah. Brothers and sisters,
alhamdulillah, this video is going to
shock you. And I believe they are going
to try to kill Candace Owens. Like if
you watch her Instagram and you know
since she's left working with Ben
Shapiro, subhan Allah, you can see
clearly, alhamdulillah. And she's
someone that speaks the truth. Like
Allah tells us in the Quran, the people
of the book are not the same. And you
can see that in her she has humanity in
her. She if anything, she follows
scripture like properly, you know. So
here is a video of her and you would be
shocked of the levels. I mean, you can't
make this stuff up. Can you imagine a
different country controlling you? A
different president and a different
country prime minister telling you what
to do and you think you're sovereign.
You're not. Look at this guys. Look at
the new laws that they are putting in
place. You'll be mind you'll be
mind-blown. Let's just switch for
ourselves. Here's what Candace Owens had
to expose.
>> For Trump, this is mask down. Okay,
people are referring to this as treason.
And that would, I think, be the accurate
term to describe what is happening here.
He is going to deny Americans in need
disaster funding if he finds out that
that city or state that is in need is
boycotting Israel.
>> You cannot make this up. Look, I know
about this for a couple I've known this
for a couple of years. Yeah. Okay.
Just imagine for a moment. Just imagine
for a moment, guys. Yeah. There's ISIS
that Muslims condemn from all walks of
life. Unless unless with Israel and
Zionists from all walks of life, they
literally say ethnic cleansing, ethnic
cleansing. They mock the death of these
children. Imagine ISIS carrying out
atrocities under Islam and the Islamic
countries are defending it, which is the
opposite. Let's suppose Yeah.
And the country says if you've gone and
there's a specific country that's
supporting it regardless of what ISIS
does and they're going through some kind
of a natural disaster hurricane and the
law comes out and says if anyone decides
to boycott ISIS you will get no relief
funds.
Just imagine this. This is the western
democracy. Americans are going to be
punished that if they boycott Israel and
they've gone through a natural disaster
where their house has been destroyed,
they've lost their family members,
they're going to be told, "No, you are
not getting no relief funding because
you boycott you boycott Israel." Let's
carry on. I hope you guys enjoyed the
video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app, brothers and
sisters. We are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kibla finder, no ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more brothers
and sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now inshallah
and enjoy, guys. Let's go back to the
video.
Okay, so we're talking about $1.9
billion in state disaster funds um that
could potentially be denied if you are a
US state or a city that is boycotting
Israeli company companies. You're just
going to be denied federal aid for a
natural disaster. Okay, this is for
natural disaster preparedness.
Obviously, there's money that comes down
from FEMA and that is what is happening.
to say specifically that you can't
decide that you're not going to maybe
invest in Israeli companies or Israeli
technology. This has nothing to do with
our company. It's an Isra. It's an
Israeli company. And you might say as a
state that we're not going to spend
money working with Israel because
they're committing a genocide in open
broad like in broad daylight. You might
say actually morally we think it is
wrong for us to in any way engage with
Israel because we are watching them
starve children daily. Let's say you get
hit by a hurricane, money that is for
the backup power systems among other
expenses.
And Trump is saying, "Yeah, no, I hear
you. I hear you screaming. I hear that
that's a hurricane and you know, maybe
it's wiped away your entire family, your
entire house. But do you support
Israel?"
>> I'm telling you, they're going to kill
this woman. I'm telling you, they are
going to kill Candace Owens. They are
going to kill her. I'm telling you guys,
Mossad that's behind the whole Epson
Islands 911. Yes, JFK is killing. Call
it whatever you like. Call it conspiracy
theory. It is the open secret. I'm
telling you, they are going to kill this
woman. They are going to kill her, guys.
Okay. Subhan, just imagine that for a
second. You are you are being denied all
of that stuff just because you say I
support Israel.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Did you boycott Israeli
tech? Yeah, I we're not going to be able
to give you this money. It doesn't your
your family doesn't qualify anymore. And
this is building upon what they already
said back in April that boycotting
Israel is is is going to be something
that they're willing to punish. And this
is not the Trump administration idea, by
the way.
>> You know, it's like, you know, they talk
about freedom of speech, like, oh,
freedom of speech, freedom of speech,
like Tommy Robinson and the, you know,
his brother talk about freedom of speed
freedom of speech, etc. Uh, subhan
Allah. They don't believe in no damn
freedom of speech. Yes. They don't
believe in no doubt freedom of speech
especially him Tommy Robinson we saw
what happened in the freedom of speech
event when me and Mhammed went and
recently his friend Liam tu who invited
me to a podcast and decided to change
his mind all of a sudden because of a
death of someone that he knew okay no
problem understandable all of a sudden
canceled and I said to him when are you
going to invite me and he's like yeah
you know um you know I I don't find the
need he contacted me and he changed his
mind why freedom of speech you guys are
liars you don't believe in freedom of
speech cuz you know I told him on the
podcast before I came I'm going to rip
your friend Tommy Robin Robinson into
shreds and pieces intellectually and he
knew that that's exactly what I'm going
to do and he doesn't believe in my
freedom of speech. He doesn't. There's a
rally that's coming out in the in
September, August, something like that.
My friend, invite me. Can I speak as a
Muslim? Nada. He's got all Islamophobes.
I am Tough. You know who you are. Yes.
You messaged me privately. Yeah. And you
canceled on me. Yeah. Liam tough. You've
got all Islamophobes and you brought one
Muslim. It's like me saying I'm not
racist. Yeah. Talking against black
people. Black people. I got one black
friend who came on. Yeah. But anyways,
you can see, let alone freedom of
speech, they don't even let you to
choose who you can buy from. This a
western democracy.
>> We have showed you the clip of BB Net
and Yahoo saying that years ago.
>> Wow. I did not know this. So, there's
actually a clip of Benjamin saying that
he's going to do it. It's like he's the
United States America, United States of
America's president. He's actually said
this in a video and they've actually
enacted it.
If you Oh my goodness gracious. Can you
imagine? Imagine Putin saying, "We're
going to change some laws in America."
It's like, "What the flipping hell are
you talking about? You You have no
control over America. You worry about
Russia." You've got a foreign
government, a foreign president. May
Allah destroy his flesh into pieces for
what he's doing to this innocent people
in Gaza.
Telling you what he's planning on doing
in America like he owns America and he
does. He owns America. That's the the
point is he owns America. You guys are
not United States of America. You are
United States of Israel. You are owned
by them. And this is the beginning of
the end of Israel. The Americans are
waking up to this.
>> You decide as an American that you don't
want to spend your dollars on anything.
You could say, "I want to I want to
boycott cereal." Right. I've decided
that I don't like Kelloggs and so I'm
going to boycott Kelloggs and I am going
to tell other people that they should.
That is your right as an American.
>> Exactly. Like you know you can boycott
Kelloggs or something else. You can say
it's not good for my kids wellbeing etc.
But a nation that is massacring
children, kids, innocent men, women,
children, babies. Nah, you cannot
boycott them. Kellogg cereal something
extra sugar in that. No, no, not good
for your kids. But a nation that's
massing children. Yeah. No, you're not
allowed to work at them.
>> Position that actually it's not your
right to do that when it comes to
Israel. Of course, you could if you want
today boycott American companies, but
Israel. Yeah. No, they're coming in now.
They're saying you can't do that. Why is
that? Because America is a sovereign
nation.
>> That's interesting. Yes. Exactly. If you
want to boycott American products, yeah,
no problem. You go ahead. You have
freedom of right to Israel. No. So, you
can even boycott American products, but
you cannot boycott Israel.
>> Now, all of a sudden, Trump is taking
the position, the extraordinary position
that actually it's not your right to do
that when it comes to Israel. Of course,
you could, if you want today, boycott
American companies, but Israel, yeah.
No, they're they're coming in now.
They're saying you can't do that. Why is
that? Because America is not a sovereign
nation. And if you are under any
illusions that America is a sovereign
nation, you need to wake up.
>> Exactly. And I just want to read an
article for you guys in just quickly
because they reversed this a couple of
days ago. This is uh on Reuters. US
reversed pledge to link disaster funds
to Israeli boycott stance. Okay. I think
they got some pressure for it. This is
actually sick. You guys are kicking the
head yet. Okay. Washington August the
3rd wrote us, "The Trump administration
on Monday reversed course on requiring
US cities and states to rebuke boycots
of Israeli companies in order to receive
disaster funds according to a statement
and deleted the earlier policy from its
website. The Department of Homeland
Homeland Security removed a statement
that said states must certify they will
not severe commercial relations
specifically with Israel companies to
qualify for the funding." Interesting.
Okay. Routers uh report on Monday that
the language applied to at least 1.9
billion that states rely on to cover
search and rescue equipment, emergency
manager salaries and backup power
systems among other expenses according
to 11 agencies, grant notices reviewed
by routters uh Reuters. This is a shift
for administration of President Donald
Trump which has previously tried to pay
penalize institutions that do not align
with its views on Israel and
anti-semitism. The disaster funding
requirement took aim at the boycott
diversement and sanctions movement
designed to put economic pressure on
Israel to end its occupation of
Palestinian territories. Right? So the
campaign supporters grew more local in
2023 after Hamas attack southern Israel
and Israel invaded Gaza in response.
Okay. Yeah. Like I said, Israel was not
doing that. You know what I'm going to
say, guys? Follow Candace Owens. This
woman, if there's trust me, there's no
suicide. This woman's life is in danger.
I'm telling you, she's speaking damn
facts. Brother and sisters, if you enjoy
this video, subscribe and like.
Inshallah. Do not forgot to download
forget to download our Salah Pro app.
Inshallah. Absolutely free. Ads free. We
don't share information with third
parties and sell them to CIA or
governmental bodies. Uh you don't have
any ads popping up left, right, center,
indecent stuff, etc. Salah Pro app is
for those who want to pray salah and be
reminded of Allah subhanaa tala. No ads
of Israel. The app that's happened with
certain ads. Subhan Allah. It's
absolutely for free. There is no catch.
You free now pay later. Nope. It is for
free. Download it now and join in. the
only app that reminds you and encourages
you to pray salah. Till next time, akum.